- All hail the Beam.
All hail the Beam.
- You may be benched.
Worshipers of the Beam,
it has been my pleasure to shepherd in a triumphant new era,
where, with every victory, the Beam grows stronger.
- All hail the Beam.
- Tonight, we shall summon the Almighty Beam,
allowing us to blot out the Western sky with its beauty.
Never again will Sac Town be thrust back into darkness.
[Alarm buzzing]
An intruder!
It can’t be...
- The prodigal son has returned!
Tyrese!
- I’ve come to shut off that damn Beam!
♪♪♪ Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Riaru-sa misetayo ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Born to be a legend ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Hikari o mezashite ♪♪♪
♪♪♪ Born to be a hero ♪♪♪
[Phone ringing]
- [Hield:] You ready for that sweet revenge?
- [Haliburton:] I’m just focused on passing right now.
But yes!
- Brother Haliburton!
Have you come to embrace the Beam?
That’s rude.
Very well.
- Beam, grant us the power of the pistol offense.
Dang corner shooters.
Buddy!
- Haha! No one shoots faster than me.
- Wait, I'm new.
I don't know what I'm doing!
- I'm getting too old for this.
I’m too young for this!
- Nothing like homemade Red Velvet.
- Now we summon the Almighty Beam.
- [Haliburton:] You’re in my spot.
- It’s Haliburton. Run!
- There are no spots in the eyes of the Beam.
[Gong]
- Look into the Beam, Tyrese!
- Never!
[Beeping]
- [Fox:] No!
- Yo.
- The...Beam?
- I go by many names.
Some call me the Almighty Beam.
Some call me stupid and ironic.
I hear you've come to destroy me.
Why?
- I...wanted revenge for being cast out...
and to prove to everyone I’m not a fake hero.
- Wally Szczerbiak is everyone now?
You were a hero here.
And you are a hero in Indiana-opolis.
Just because the beam shines doesn't mean you don't shine.
You need to...find your own beam.
- Find my own beam.
[Ringing]
- [Hield:] You ready for that sweet revenge?
Where are you going?
- That’s someone else’s problem.
Let’s find our own beam.
- I was not expecting that answer to be that deep.
You good, bro?
- The Beam from the north is too powerful!
We must offer up a sacrifice to protect the cap!
- Oh, whoa! Whoa! Wait!